uh look at the end of the day uh i think
i've been more nervous for this pog
champs than any other pog champs
i don't know why even my poops have been
weird today and i think it's because
i've been nervous
i we didn't
the game is sort by the way it is a um
it is it is a scotch opening
so ludwig correctly plays i believe
little is white right yeah so he
correctly plays bishop to e3 does not
play c3 like xqc did against
uh moist critical in the previous match
where he played with c3 queen f6 knight
takes c6 queen takes f2 checkmate
uh lotus plays bishop to e3 which i
think he is prepared
well it looks like i was not oh logic
blunders on
oh no yeah and as i was saying that our
screen sharing software caught up uh
we've got a blunder oh man
this is bad oh yikes
and this is i think the big danger i
think um is the opening phase when i've
seen several of these players like um
logic and xqc in particular i feel like
both of them are very talented players
once they get out of the opening phase
of the game but in the opening phase
if they get into trouble they can end up
too far behind to come back
and i think so far very unfortunate
start for uh for logic and i think
ludwig should win this game he's up a
juicer already he's got two bishops
tonight against the bishop tonight
smooth sailing if he takes care of
business
i'm just drawing arrows one of my arrows
has been played okay i'm not do you like
this move i mean i just simplifying as
long as he stabilizes like rook v8 could
be annoying
you know there's tactics rook b2 yeah
i love c5 i think for ludwig it's great
to trade
now it's a critical moment probably the
last critical moment i would say the
game where logic can maybe come back
because if uh if ludwig is able to
develop the bishop and castle the king
or move the queen and castle the king
and avoid getting into trouble here
he should win the game that's a solid
move but let's see if it works
i just think that this threat although
met with this
is results in a pretty fierce group here
which i don't know if necessarily is
that bad for me if i'm castling kingside
but
i think normally in games especially
around my level
the b2 g2 b7 g7
pawns are oftentimes captured by the
queen and that can be make or break for
either side
for the capturer or the uh the defender
and why enter a situation like that when
i can just play a normal developing move
perfect spot on yeah and again i mean
it's it's obviously winning for white
with correct play but it's still if
you're ludwig you're a little bit
concerned because i think ludwig really
wants to castle
uh kingside and i think he's probably a
little bit nervous to push the f pawn
here
yeah exactly f3 is probably one of the
best moves he might also play bishop
back to e2
that would be a great move also
yeah bishop e2 just trades the bishop i
th the worry is that he plays queen d2
okay plays f3 f3 is good yeah it's also
good
yeah queen d2 would have been bad
because of bishop f3
and now i have a bad feeling logic is
okay okay that's a good move bishop is a
great move now the question here is will
ludwig see the castle queen side
and he does actually see it which is
which is important so it goes queen e3
i think if ludwig can get his king
castle as the king side he's very likely
going to win this match
that's what i would say perhaps worth
putting my king b2
soft very soft move wise
but since there's no dark squared bishop
it's pretty
sound yes not the worst idea ever but
you are in the
face of the pins so and like right now
this is like
kind of like it's like when i watch like
better people play chess where we are
just improving our position but we have
no real actual breaks happening until
just then yeah that huh i just wish
though
because if okay so takes
takes takes
man he's so lucky queen a1 is not just
made right
sure i don't think i'm missing anything
oh man
well he might see it now right before he
does it if we just pull this up like
whoa bishop f5 is a really sneaky move
yeah wow that's a very sneaky move by
um by logic look at that he he notices
the change in the position
and he he's man i would love it if black
had these b and d
rooks that would be oh man
oh no oh no oh my god it's pond
no way pontics pond come on logic take
the juicer
no way logic might be playing this in a
tricky way like he's maintaining the
pressure on d5 but he
if he takes knight d5 he'll spot queen
a1 it shook me yeah
you just got to go just take the pawn
yeah he did have it in his plans to play
king b2 i don't know if logic ended up
seeing that queen a1
keep saying both of their names for the
other person i don't think ludwig
saw that after knight d5 there was queen
a1 but
uh oh he hung me oh oh no
oh my god
he hugged me
[Music]
oh he's a god oh
he hasn't he had no idea he's a god
what a god that is heartbreaking
oh my god no i mean it wasn't it wasn't
a godly move i mean he just he
maintained the tension there ludwig
he carl ludwig had tunnel vision on the
night move so he just did it
but he didn't oh my gosh
crazy oh that is heartbreaking
yeah because you know how much prep went
into the opening there ludwig's
ludwig prepared that opening he got
everything he wanted he got the trick he
got the piece
and then he just hung queen a1 man
crazy absolutely crazy oh that is
absolutely heartbreaking
but did you see the the life vanish from
my face
on to game two just as hard
ludwig by the way has played uh
the queen d6 scandinavian so if anybody
wants a very easy opening to
to play get get that scandinavian and uh
play this so someone's done some videos
on i feel like
someone oh wait but you you recommended
queen a5 right levy no i
i i talk a little bit about everything
but thank you for plugging me yeah
that's uh great great see
we're like volleyball you know but but
will he play
a6 okay he clearly has done his breath
isn't this exactly
his game against charlie was this exact
opening but i think charlie went bishop
e2 and so he didn't go b5
but in this case logic did put the
bishop on c4 so he did play b5 which is
very good
yes it looks kind of scary like i i mean
it looks like the queen is just like
it's it's
really near your bishop i think and it
just it looks scary optically
so oh no oh look oh my gosh logic just
logic just gambits a bishop to start
this game too
oh wow okay yo what is this guys guys
is this does does logic think he can
think he's bobby fischer or something he
can spot his opponent an extra bishop
every game
that maybe i mean if ludwig's gotta win
now i i
i oh come on come on
what's he saying i want to hear this i'm
up an entire piece
you go for it man you do you
i feel you bro but i'm just gonna go d8
man
annoying stuff because yeah i mean logic
is playing not to lose cons
considering he won the first game so one
and a half oh he's going for the big
cheese
the big cheese now if ludwig plays queen
f6 here queens are coming off the board
and there will be no excuse for him to
not win the game yeah he
he sees it one move he sees it and he's
trying to play f6
ooh ooh
[Music]
yeah he is you just push
don't push don't just push push don't
push push
but if i push what changes in the
position well my king
is no longer protected so he goes
check nice he saw it yeah
perfect great everybody benefits he
yells a lot
he can take and then win the bit of the
rook
so that's not the best move there you go
in fact
how about we just make this really
obvious about what i want to have happen
good just play clean out six yeah
[Music]
oh he said queen here oh oh oh there it
is
yeah that's the the way that he worked
protect that
i don't really good cheeky checks the
way that he worked that out
out um not to do the pun but the way
that he worked out the sequence
was perfect literally perfect the way
perfect queen f6 and absolutely perfect
that was uh that was super very clean
yeah
and if ludwig doesn't win here i mean he
doesn't deserve to
you know to win the match i mean because
this one he's he's definitely got it
he's got it going here
queens have to come off the board he's
gonna be way ahead by at least one
piece so i mean this is this is it for
ludwig he's got he's got to uh
he's got he's got to get it done yeah
for logic to now come out of this
without losing any material he probably
has to like take the queen and then take
on c6 right
right and it's too limited just too
limited so i i think ludwig is gonna win
here
really i mean the thought process there
was absolutely brilliant by ludwig the
way that he worked out f6 is the queen
h5
queen e7 then realizing why don't i make
it really simple and really obvious and
now
logic just hangs a second juicer in the
middle of the board
yeah queen takes knight and um and then
ludwig is going to coast to victory
but i still still feel like it's very
easy to sort of lose your mind and
panic after that first game which is
like what happened like and you just
kind of want to move really fast but one
was being very slow very methodical and
he's really working it through
yeah like exactly he said f6 and a lot
of us just go
f6 oh that looks pretty good but never
in the history of chess haven't you ever
thrown plus six
well but surely i could find out a way
to make it happen
[Music]
oh man uh it's like it's like those
basketball teams you know uh let it be a
lesson no one ever beats us by more than
30 you know
by 29. so uh no he's got a point he
deserves
he deserves both games frankly but he
wandered that first one
yeah real i i think ludwig realizes that
he's ahead by a bishop and a knight so
it doesn't matter you just want to make
sure queens and rooks come off the board
if you can
if you're gonna offer the trade so queen
five is the best move
and logic either has to trade queens
or play queen d3 or queen e2 and neither
of those moves are gonna get the job
done
so right yeah i think it's very likely
we're gonna have uh
we're gonna have a have a five minute
game for all the marbles
and ludwig gets white because okay yeah
knight g5 okay now just swap and that's
all she wrote that's game over
yeah please don't go rook t8 oh my god
please don't go rook t8
that would be insane
and now you can laterally swing it to d7
or e7 what a move
yes rook d8 rushing with the trade would
have resulted in rook e8
you lose a knight and then you're
paralyzed yeah that would have been that
would have been a serious throw so rook
a7 is a great move
yeah also rookie 7 is kind of a rook
lift
again remember in his match against
moist critical he missed a rook lift
so it's kind of like and rick actually
rookie seven is the best move
white can't sit white's gonna have to
trade us out straight off rooks here
and then white's left with one rook and
and ludwig should win this pretty
cleanly
yes very nice conversion from him yeah
it's never or
i mean actually it is true though if you
don't see f5
it is kind of tricky to play here like
king c2 now
you got to go kingston too then work d2
checking you can use the other pony to
make the chucks but
okay now knight c3 and rook d1 it's an
arabian checkmate knight
three and it's the the arabian mate here
does he
i mean he also can go rook d1 and then
knight c3 so
yeah he but the thing is if he's not
confident after that first game
he's gonna think he messed up and now
he's gonna go panic mode and
play like knight takes f2 which is still
winning
right but ludwig's been very composed
here he seems very composed and very
measured
so i don't think he's just gonna panic
here uh now if he had like 30 seconds i
could see it but not with three minutes
on the clock
um i kind of think rook d1 is the move
he should be able to spot here
right because it's just like you know
what they're gonna do
they're gonna take and then knight c3
but so
he had almost dr he almost played knight
g2 check and
i found it nice wow dude nice move by by
ludwig
very nice move yeah and that's it it's
mate yep sick suck me
very nice game bye bye
strictly better strictly better there's
nothing
else to say
go ahead no i was to say we got a scotch
and i was just
okay uh did did logic prepare something
because yeah he did he improves i i was
sure he had an improvement
i don't like this line improvement line
though necessarily i
still would have played bishop b6 yes to
guards
i don't i thought the idea of bishop b6
and knight f6 is even if it's not
correct at the grand master level it's a
simple free-flowing plan
playing queen r6 is much more
double-edged that being said
look at ludwig he's deep in the tank if
white doesn't know what to do it can be
very dangerous for white as well
i love queen a4 by lovely even if it's
not the best move i love it it's
aggressive
oh no no no no although
i'm not taking with the pawn there oh he
might play king b8 dude he might play
king b8 ju
oh my gosh queen a7 tunneling he's just
tunneling the whole queen side oh man oh
now he's gotta really just okay b6 queen
eight is made
and oh c6 this should be six
that's actually i don't hate that move
man i don't hate that move and if black
can get the knife to f4 he has all kinds
of threats with checkmates
yeah that rook is guarded and it's
getting closer on time it's about 10
seconds now
okay we went a lot uh we went to ludwig
[Music]
he hung his knife oh no rook takes
knight oh no
oh my gosh that's insane wait let's
let's just bring that back
um oh
rook takes knight and now queen f2 queen
g2 is just game over
like yeah and oh and he's queen of two
oh no
oh no oh no
logic misses it queen of two
oh no the only one oh we missed it
and now he's
and then queen c8 and there's actually a
staircase checkmate oh man
logic through maybe seven's mate mate
rookie 27 27 there's three mates here
for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw
let's go the question is lovely realized
that he was meeting and [__]
that's actually the big question victory
it's a swing
to realize that it was meeting two is
the question that's actually what
i'm curious about i was scared for a
moment there was some
f2 action oh he he sees it
yeah it doesn't matter what this chat's
going to definitely tell him now for
sure
i just want you to tell me uh to tell
tell everybody what you told me man
because your mentality through all this
you know
people people in a game like that would
be stressed angry
your mentality is very different so i
mean i'm going home to a fine ass woman
and a baby so i'm happy i mean and at
the end of the day this is for charity
this is my first time and i i wouldn't
want to easy win
like it was very you know he played
really great
and yeah there's nerves that come with
it when you have thousands and thousands
of people watching you it's not like
performing that's easy that's what i do
like i say like i'm a rapper i'm not a
chess player professionally
even though i love the game so there's
things that i miss there's things that
i still don't see and i don't
necessarily see it as a negative
you know because people could be [__]
boys about it and try to be like oh you
lost or you this you that's like no i
won i made money for a charity and i'm
happy
but i did take a l to my man's bloodwork
today so
i will wholeheartedly admit that um but
you know missing things like
like in this in this last game with the
with the mate in two
um it just gets me more excited to
further learn the language of chess and
have the vision for it so at the end of
the day it's like we had fun
um you know it's all going to charity
and hopefully you guys will let me come
back because i'm about to be i'm gonna
be on it now
ludwig congrats man now you gotta
you gotta top that off man how do you
feel how'd you bounce back is two
matches now where you you
you start with the with the 01 what do
you do to
what do you do to get hyped up motivated
to
to win it after taking a loss in the
first game i think
logic is is uh i mean a hell of a public
speaker but everything he says
is uh is resoundingly true that like
i got checkmated on on a1
and i will that will never happen to me
again and so the biggest takeaway is uh
i've improved my game of chess so that's
i can uh i can i can take that away but
i felt good
after i got a dm from hess my best
friend magnus we were chatting a bit
about like you know thank you uh yeah
where finland is on the map um but i i
felt fine
because um because i was winning in the
opening and i think that was
where i cause i don't know dude logic is
crazy man it's like no matter what i did
he always had an attack
and it was terrifying that i was up six
in game two
and i was second guessing everything i
was doing because of game one in part
but it doesn't matter how many pieces
i'm up by he just always has an attack
in mind
and uh and if you don't know how to deal
with it it's terrifying
i also think sometimes like i'm so
focused on that attack or looking for a
check
that i leave a piece hanging you know
yeah second game i really did mess up
with that bishop and i should have just
brought it back for sure
but i don't know why it's like saw that
square i was like i'll be fine here
and your night ticket is hilarious yeah
it was an early lead and that made it
feel better but um
i mean hats off to you because it did
not feel good um
one getting stomps game one and then
game three was
terrible i felt terrible the whole time
i started just a nod in my stomach
i think that's a very very good
mentality well we got we got ludwig
you're
you're going into the semi-final yeah um
you know there's been a lot made of the
the different players involved in the
semi-final there's
it's a lot of players you yourself i
heard you on a stream one say you
thought you might be the worst player in
the champions bracket i don't want you
to think that way we got logic here
he's hyping it all up you're you're in a
semi-final with rayne wilson
and benji fishy saying it out loud
doesn't change the fact i yes
exactly what you said i am in a
semi-final with benji fishy
a 16 year old cracked genius sardoche
like a 1500 man
and then rayne wilson i am not sitting
pretty in this tournament but
uh look at the end of the day uh i think
i've been more nervous for this pog
champs than any other pog champs
i don't know why even my poops have been
weird today and i think it's because
i've been nervous
i uh we didn't all right well i'm just
letting you know
that this is what pogchamps is doing to
me it's sucking my soul away levy
okay all i can do is go out there and
play the best chess i can and
if that's enough hell yeah and if it's
not then shame but
that's all i got
[Music]